- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk about
how you can be a better leader.
The why clip is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips
as well as my thoughts.
And as always, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
something that really hit the mark,
please leave it in the comments below,
put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired as well, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- I think building an
organization and building a team.
The idea that Jack Welch is the hero
of creating all his value is silly.
Getting great people in all these jobs,
it's a team that makes this thing happen.
And so building a team
is your strongest suit.
And you got to love your team.
You got to want your team to be promoted.
And when you're coming up,
the biggest problem I find with young MBAs
at first the job is you shining,
raising your hand, having the answers.
They want to do that all the time.
They just got out of school,
they want to show you how smart they are.
Now the transition to
manager it all changes.
It's about growing your people, not you.
You grow from the reflected
glory of your people.
So it's all about making them flourish.
I like to use the line, that
your job is walking around
with a can of water in one hand,
a can of fertilizer in the other hand,
sprinkling on the seeds
and watching them grow.
You'll get some weeds and you
got to pull those weeds out.
So everyone's not going to flourish,
but you've got to be
thinking about all the time
loving to see your people thrive,
loving to see them get promoted.
It's a real turn on.
It is what management is all about.
It's about bringing to people
great lives, great futures.
Changing their family's
life, that's a turn on.
It's a big deal, that's
what you got to think about.
- My number one belief about leadership is
you're a servant.
And here what I mean specifically.
The word hero, that is in the archetype
of men and you and I, I bet.
Is it true that inside of you,
you want you to be the best,
you want to create the best,
share the best, do the best,
is that a metaphor for you in your life?
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, me too.
So I think people in this room
tend to have that as their metaphor.
So all of us at some level, man
or woman wants to be a hero.
The word "hero", in it's
Latin root means servo.
Servo means servant.
It actually means slave.
The hero, why they're the hero
is become the ultimate servant
of something larger than themself.
People and so forth.
The person who thinks
they're going to lead
by demand or by position can only lead
for a short period of time.
But the person whose idea is serving
is my belief is, if you can find a way
to take any group of people and help them
to experience their needs at a richer,
deeper level than anyone else,
then together, you guys
can get anything done.
Anything.
Now it may not work the first time,
but together you can get to that point.
'Cus needs are ultimately
what we're after.
We're not after the vehicle
we think we're after.
You get a billion dollars
and then you get it,
I got plenty of clients and I'll tell you
it is not the end game.
And so then they go after
their second billion.
Or you think it's getting married
and you get it and you find out
it's not the end game.
There are certain needs
that have to be there.
And the ultimate needs
are growing and giving.
'Cus you can only feel so
good filled up by yourself.
So my core belief is, I got to serve.
If I serve I can lead.
Because I believe motive does matter.
If my motive is just to get
you to do something for me,
there's a certain amount of power
that I can get to do that.
If I strategize, if I think, if I feel,
and also if it serves a greater good.
Even if I don't intend it.
If the bumblebee goes to try
to get the nectar it wants,
it's selfish goal,
I believe there's a higher
power that guides it all.
And when that bumblebee goes
it doesn't intend to give anything,
but pollen sticks to its legs.
As it goes about trying
to get what it wants
that's how flowers are created.
I really believe that everything
has a web of connection.
If your intent is to serve yourself,
you're still going to serve
something more than yourself
and you're going to get a
certain amount of insight.
If your intent and your motive
is to serve something yourself,
but also something more, just your kids,
then I believe you get a
different level of insight.
And because it's serving
more of what serves life.
It's not just me, it's me and my family.
If you're trying to serve a community
I believe you get a
different level of insight.
Trying to serve humanity
you get a different level of insight.
I get emotional thinking about it
'cus this is why I do what I do.
So when someone stands up
it's not about business,
it's not about anything,
but about serving them.
So I will use abrasive
or creative language
I'll use whatever it takes.
Humor, stupidity, I'll make
fun of myself, I'll challenge,
I'll do anything to serve
that's why I'm here.
I don't need to do this anymore,
but I love to see someone
free, alive, and lit up.
So when that's your motive,
no matter how people perceive you outside
if they're around you long enough
you can't hide what your real motive is.
And they'll see it and they'll feel it.
Motive does matter.
If it's to serve something higher
that doesn't mean you
don't get served too.
And in business you got to be served or
I used to do business and I'd
lose money in the business
and everybody else was happy.
And it was wonderful
except I had no business.
So it's killing the goose
that lays the golden eggs.
So I've learned to put that balance in,
but that gives me power.
That's why time disappears for me.
'Cus I'm not about
getting some action done,
I'm about the outcome.
- My first job out of
college I had a boss who
believed it was appropriate to
berate people to get the most of them.
And I remember, this is a true story,
I actually sat down with her,
we used to have these
monthly career updates.
And she literally said to
me, "You have no talent."
And I went, "None?"
And she said, "None."
And the good news was I
thought that was funny.
'Cus you can't have none.
Like if you told me I
could only do one thing
that actually probably
would have hurt more,
but nothing.
And so I really paid attention
as to how she managed
and the rest of my career
did the complete opposite.
- Give me an example.
- I think pointing out people's strengths
is a lot better than telling
them they have no talent.
Also she had this belief
that if you don't look
harried and insane then
you're not working hard.
So I remember pretending
that I was stressed out.
'Cus if I sauntered down the hallway
and said hi to people she
thought I was doing nothing.
So I started pretending, I'd be like,
"(sighs) I can't talk, I can't talk,"
and that way she thought I was very busy
and she left me alone.
Yeah, honestly in management, you know.
Treating people with respect,
being honest about what
they can and can't do,
and committing yourself to helping people,
not hurting people and pushing them down
has been more effective for me.
- Sometimes at work it's
not what's happening at work
for a lot of stressed
out managers especially,
it's what's happening outside of work.
How do you try to figure
out where the source is
of the issue maybe to cut
past some of the challenges
you face communicating?
- When I was entry-level,
having empathy for my boss
didn't factor in.
Not knowing anything
about sort of my place
in the company and et cetera.
But as I've grown up I realized
that the only motivation for
any kind of confrontation
whether you're the one
who's confronting someone
because you feel that they
have done something wrong
or whether you're confronting them
because you feel that you've been wronged
the only motivation is empathy.
And so even if someone is
coming down on me hard,
or being unreasonable, or being you know.
I'm not perfect at it,
but I've worked really hard to approach it
with confronting them that
they hurt me or I feel wronged,
but immediately go into
considering that maybe there's
something that's bothering them.
And that has proved to be really helpful.
And we do it in life.
I mean for example,
somebody sitting next to you
on the subway is slouched
back they're legs open
and your immediate reaction
is to think, "What an ass,"
but the idea of practicing and say,
"Well maybe he had a hard day yesterday
and he's exhausted and he
just doesn't want to deal."
Maybe he doesn't want to talk to people.
To really just have empathy
for the world around you.
It's kind of powerful,
and people respond to
you a lot better as well
because basically everybody
wants to feel safe.
And so if you have empathy
you give that to people
up or down the chain of command.
I mean we as employees want to feel safe.
It is our bosses
responsibility to give us that,
but at the same time
bosses want to feel safe.
They don't want to feel
that there's insurrection
that's brewing.
And for us to let them know
that we've got their back
as much as we want them to let us know
that they have ours is
equally as important.
And I believe there is
responsibility of a manager,
but there's a responsibility
of an employee as well.
It's like the kids have
to do chores at home.
That's the kind of same thing.
It's like we all, it takes all of us.
The hierarchy doesn't mean
that only the guys above
are the ones with responsibility.
We all have to contribute.
- One of the keys to Apple is
Apple is an incredibly
collaborative company.
And so...
You know how many
committees we have at Apple?
- [Interviewer] No.
- Zero.
We have no committees.
- [Interviewer] No committees.
- We are organized like a start-up.
One person is in charge
of iPhone OS software.
One person is in charge of Mac hardware.
One person is in charge of
iPhone hardware engineering.
Another person is in charge
of world wide marketing.
Another person is in charge of operations.
We're organized like a start-up.
We're the biggest start-up on the planet.
And we all meet
for three hours once a week
and we talk about everything we're doing.
The whole business.
And there's tremendous team
work at the top of the company
which filters down to tremendous team work
throughout the company.
And team work is dependent
on trusting the other folks
to come through with their part
without watching them all the time,
but trusting that they're
going to come through
with their parts.
And that's what we do really well.
And we're great at figuring out
how to divide things up into
these great teams that we have
and all work on the same
thing, touch bases frequently,
and bring it all together into a product.
We do that really well.
And so what I do all day is
meet with teams of people.
And work on ideas and solve problems,
to make new products, to
make new marketing programs,
whatever it is.
- And are people willing
to tell you you're wrong?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I mean other
than snarky journalists
I mean people that work for you.
- Oh yeah, no we have wonderful arguments.
- [Interviewer] And do
you win them all or?
- Oh no, I wish I did.
Well see, you can't.
If you want to hire great people
and have them stay working for you
you have to let them
make a lot of decisions
and you have to be won
by ideas not hierarchy.
The best ideas have to win.
Otherwise good people don't stay.
- When you begin leading a new business
or take on a new leadership
role in a business
you'd usually be relatively inexperienced
in the constant thrust
of business activities.
Because of your lack of experience
you will go into business
with the wrong people
and hire the wrong people and get involved
with the wrong people at many levels.
Now this is normal and natural
and it's to be expected at the beginning.
The key is to always be growing
as a person and as a leader.
As you continue to grow and learn
it will reflect on all parts of your life
and in all parts of your business.
There's a universal principle
that you've heard of
called the Law of Attraction.
This law says that you
always attract into your life
the people, and ideas,
and resources, and harmony
with your dominant thoughts.
The fact is that you are a living magnet.
Like iron filings are
attracted to a magnet
you'll attract into your life the people
who are in harmony with your current level
of knowledge and wisdom and experience.
The good news is that as your
leadership skills grow and mature,
you'll attract into your life
better and better people.
You'll attract better
employees, and better customers,
and better suppliers, and better bankers,
and better associates.
But you'll always get the
people that you deserve
based on your current level of
personal and professional development.
The more you learn and grow,
the more experiences you
have that you benefit from
and the wiser you become
as a business person
the faster and more consistently
your business will grow as well.
You'll always attract the type of people
who are in harmony with your own level
of personal development.
The rule is your life only
gets better on the outside
when you get better on the inside.
Now your people only get better
when you become a better manager.
Your customers only get better
when you become a better sales person.
Your business only gets better
when you become a better business person.
There are no shortcuts
and there's no other way.
Fortunately you are in complete control
of every aspect of your life.
So always be improving yourself
and you'll start to improve
every other aspect of your life
around you including your
leadership abilities.
Continue to improve your leadership skills
and qualities by practicing these things.
Read in your field on a regular basis.
Always be reading about the best practices
and leadership skills that you can use
in your personal development as a leader.
And try them out everyday.
Listen to audio programs on
business and leadership success.
And try out what you
learn in those programs.
Attend business seminars.
This is one of the greatest
learning tools in history.
You can gain new perspectives and ideas
relating to your field
and then put these ideas into action.
Share ideas in your
business mastermind groups
and gain ideas from other people.
If something is working well
for someone else in your field
there's a good chance it
will work for you as well.
Use other people's great
ideas to improve on yourself.
As you improve on the inside,
your business and every part of you life
will improve on the outside.
The only limits on what you
can accomplish in your business
are those limits you set on
yourself with your own thinking.
You can go as fast and far as you want
on your way to wealth,
it's completely up to you.
- A boss's entire job
is to get the combined
intellect of his team
to be raised to a new level
and to instill spirit.
Find everyway to celebrate.
Find every excuse to have a party.
Every little victory counts.
It is so, if a boss can't energize
if he or she can't excite
and make people want to be there
they shouldn't have that title.
- So if we think about my
philosophy on leadership
I believe that it's a leader's job
to identify the limiting beliefs
that hold the people on their team back.
I think you need to help
the people on your team
believe in themselves more,
and help them expose these things
that have been holding them back,
and give them the path to break through,
and give them the confidence, and courage,
and abilities to break through.
I think it's important that when you are
challenging somebody to
push, and grow, and learn,
and get better that it's all done
with their self interest
in mind not yours.
And often those will be aligned.
Somebody's self interest to
be a better sales person,
a better programmer, a
better graphic designer.
If that's one of their ambitions,
that's great for you too being the leader.
Sometimes it means that you
push them away from the company.
It means that they have to
go off and do something else
'cus their dream is to be a baker
and you don't have an
opportunity for baking
in your company.
So don't stick with me and
be a C or D player here
go be an A player over there.
People will only do something
for you for so long.
If you are forcing
someone into do something,
forcing them to show up on time,
forcing someone to hit this deadline,
forcing someone to grow,
they will do it for a while
'cus you're paying the bills.
Because maybe they respect you,
because maybe they want to make you happy,
but when people will really give you
everything they've got is
because they see how it benefits them.
It's because it's in their
best interest to do it
and it's not a sales job,
it's not trying to convince them
that doing this action is
going to be good for them.
It's truly coming from a place of
I want you to get better for yourself.
Whether that means you stay
with our company or not
if you are going to be around us
you are going to get better.
We are going to help you break through
these limiting personal beliefs,
these actions that are holding you back.
And I think a good leader
brings that with them.
They bring a desire to make
everything around them better.
The people around them better,
the environment around them better,
the customers around them better
because it's in their best
interest and not yours.
And they happen to line
up a lot of the times
which helps you in your business.
So that's my quick take.
I'd love to know what do
you think about leadership?
What are some of the
skills that you've learned
some of the tricks,
tactics that you've learned
that helped you become a better leader?
Or some of the things that
you are trying to learn,
please leave in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Also what was your favorite
clip in this video?
What did you learn the most from
some of the people who
shared some thoughts today.
Leave in the comments again
I'll join the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
abhishek asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of Believe Life
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
Finally I wanted to give
a quick shout out to
local Toronto entrepreneur Frank Hoffmann.
Frank thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book.
Thank you for tweeting
that awesome picture out.
I know there's a lot of other
people's books in that picture,
but Your One Word is on the top
and so I really appreciate that Frank.
I hope you enjoy the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- So there's a wonderful
story about listening.
There's the problem when people say
you need to be a better listener
is we are human beings and
we need to communicate.
And communication is two
ways listening and speaking.
So everybody's like you got
to be a better listener.
But here's the best
understanding I have of it.
So Nelson Mandela is universally
regarded as a great leader.
Which is important
because different people
are viewed differently
in different nations,
but Nelson Mandela universally
regarded as a great leader.
He was actually the son of a tribal chief.
And he was asked in an interview once,
"How did you learn to be a great leader?"
And he tells the story of how he would go
to tribal meetings with his father
and he remembers two things.
They always sat in a circle
and his father was
always the last to speak.
And in terms of leadership and listening,
I think the idea of be a better listener
is actually half the advice.
I think the advice is practice
being the last to speak.
You see this all the time in meetings
where everybody will sit around a room
the senior guy will be like,
"Alright here's the problem,
"here's what I think we should do,
"but I'm really interested
in what your thoughts are
"so let's go around the room."
It's too late.
You've influenced the room.
- You created the footprint.
- And people bend and
mold as opposed to saying,
"Here's the problem I'm interested
in what you have to say."
Without saying anything and not even,
this takes practice,
not even giving a hint
whether you agree or disagree.
If anything you ask
questions to learn more.
You get the benefit of
hearing everybody's opinion,
everybody gets to feel heard,
and then you get to render your opinion.
- Is part of the interviewing process
do you essentially culture check?
- Yes, but not like a checklist.
Culture's always something
that we interview for.
Of kind of curiosity and it's
easy to find people who say,
"Oh I read the Netflix culture deck
"I love it I really want to be there."
What's harder is what are the main things
you disagree with and why?
And when we get a blank stare we're like,
okay not really a first principle thinker
and when they say,
"Well I thought the way
that you didn't talk about
"how to acculturate and if
I'm not great in day three
"am I out or is there,
"do you look at it like an athlete
"where it's over some time
period to prove yourself
"and if so, what's that time period
"and why haven't you clarified that?"
Then we're like, "Oh yeah,
that's a good insight."
First principle thinker.
So we're looking for
people who are curious,
typically self confident,
and they're questioning
everything around them.
- Another important quality
in an effective leader
is to be a role model.
To be the kind of person
that everyone else
looks up to, wants to be like.
This is true in your work,
in your personal life,
it's true in your family,
but it's also true as a manager.
Effective leaders carry
themselves at all times
even when no one is watching,
as if everyone was watching.
Leaders imagine that they
live in a gold fish bowl
and everyone is watching the
leader in the leadership role.
They're very aware of the impact
of their words and gestures
on the people around them.
They realize that what they
say has tremendous impact.
So you must always be sensitive
to the fact that everything you say or do
is magnified many times by
the people who look up to you
or look up to you for guidance.
A positive remark from you to someone
over whom you exert influence or control
has inordinately positive effects.
A negative remark or criticism from you
has inordinately negative effects.
The impact of both are multiplied.
So choose your words and
your behavior with care.
If you aspire to become an
inspirational and effective
leader you must continuously
work on yourself
and improve your management skills.
No one starts off as an
effective leader or manager,
but you can aspire to improve your skills
by learning what leaders
do, and how they think,
and how they feel, and
then by copying them
until you become one yourself.
Remember leaders are made not born
and they are self made
through personal development.